[Music]
the brain is a tremendous organism that
helps all of us and brain obviously
functions for our cognitive function it
functors for our well-being for our
mindfulness for how we interact with
others and I want to start to tell you a
couple of stories that I think gives us
the flavor of what we need for long-term
brain health the first is an experiment
was initially done in mice and then it
was done in humans and that is touch the
power of touch if you take a mouse and
you take it away from other mice and put
a loan all of a sudden it gets more
immune problems
it gets more disease it takes longer to
get over infections you put it back so
it's touched all the time it goes back
to the way it was a much quicker getting
over when it gets sick and the same is
true in humans we were designed to be
social and so people who were loners
that have spent all their day alone
where there's no touch or no other human
interactions don't do well so you need
to figure out a way to get that touch
people who live with someone cohabitate
live longer than people who live alone
so figure out a way to do it and figure
out a way to change your life go to out
tonight find somebody obviously I'm not
pushing you to you know live with
somebody right away you gotta feel it
with the right person because that other
side of it is stress is bad and when you
have relationships that pull you down
it's very hard for all of us so there's
an old Buddhist expression detach and
transcend and I want you to do that
start to take a look at your
relationships both good and bad when
it's difficult and when you see a
relationship really makes you crabby
whenever you're with this person it's
you in a different mood and really
affects you you need to figure out a way
to get away from that obviously you
can't eliminate all your family because
many of those are family members but you
have to figure out a way so that those
interactions don't bring you down and
hurt the rest of your life I want you to
take that twenty thousand foot view of
you to look at your social interactions
because I think that's key because life
is a marathon and I think it's key to go
that marathon and do well is to have
design correctly at the same time I want
you to be mindful of you I want you to
figure out what is the best scheduling
ways to deal with your life so for
example we know is that downtime is
important
downtime everyday is actually what
allows what happened during the day to
sink in so if a child is at school all
day studying studying studying it has no
downtime they're not gonna remember as
much as if they have that downtime the
end of the day so figure out a way to do
it for your children and for yourself
you know for me it's that drive home
that drive home I turn off my devices
and I'd like to listen to some music
classic rock which my kids make fun of
me for listening to and that's my
downtime and it actually works at the
same time the brain needs quiet there
was a study done in Europe where they
looked at circles around an airport the
closer you were to it the higher the
rate of cognitive decline so figure out
a way to get that quiet time so whether
you live in a city whether you live next
to noisy neighbors figure out a way at
night will you have that time I wear
those earplugs at night why because my
dog snores and I need to figure out a
way that I can get the quiet time I'm a
brain can actually read it self together
for the next day you know we all respond
to stress differently and today's world
there are metrics we can actually
measure stress and we can measure stress
in each of us so figure out what it is
you know to me it's playing with the dog
it's reading a book it's taking a walk
in nature and they work for me but
figure out what works for you and use a
metric and I also know you know when my
shoulders go up I'm in that yellow zone
I'm starting to get a little bit of
stress and I figure out a way to go back
to green to less stress so figure out a
way to do it for you know yourself you
look back to the greatest writers of
medicine and this is what it astounds me
2,000 years ago
Hippocrates wrote really the foundations
of what medicine is today and the
foundation of it was to know yourself
and he would look and say when I ate
this I felt good or I felt bad and
that's how he started to get these
intuitions about health and I want you
to do it for you to personalize
for yourself
[Music]